Olá meus amigos minhas amigas sejam
bem-vindos a mais uma live do grupo de
apoiadores é um prazer estar com vocês
hoje é feriado aqui no Estado de São
Paulo revolução
constitucionalista de
32 e eu queria pedir um apoio de vocês
para prestigiar o canal alternativo o
canal do
vlog porque realmente a plataforma tem
atrapalhado a difusão de vídeos de saúde
especialmente os de saúde alternativa
então canal alternativo eu quero que ele
cresça e aí se você não estiver inscrito
ainda vá lá se inscrever no canal do
vlog e lá tem um vídeo interessante que
eu coloquei o
link nosso grupo de WhatsApp que é sobre
uma doença autoimune nova que impede a
ação da vitamina B12 no cérebro então
mesmo que a pessoa tenha B12 normal no
sangue por conta de um alto corpo contra
um receptor Chamado CD 320 um receptor
de vitamina B12 no cérebro a pessoa
acaba tendo problemas cognitivos a taxia
etc porque não está faltando vitamina
B12 mas porque o receptor de vitamina B2
do cérebro tá com problema então dê uma
olhadinha nesse vídeo lá no canal
alternativo e se você tiverem dúvidas a
gente pode estar respondendo também bem
vamos aqui discutir alguns artigos
Boa noite Carlos que está ao vivo com a
gente quem tiver entrando por favor se
identifique Dê um alô para poder também
cumprimentar vocês então eu separei
alguns artigos aqui pra gente conversar
na Live de
hoje primeiro artigo é um estudo que
investiga como é que o uso de um enag
bucal com carboidrato poderia melhorar o
desempenho durante exercícios de
resistência ou seja exercício de força
né musculação especificamente e aqui
Eles estudaram um dos exercícios que é o
levantamento terra então é uma coisa bem
curiosa né só enxaguar o carboidrato na
boca em vez de
engolir poderia fazer diferença no
treino vamos descobrir juntos isso daí
então no estudo os pesquisadores
investigaram seu uso de enxaguante bucal
com carboidrato poderia melhorar o
desempenho em exercício de força ou
resistência e os resultados avaliados
incluíram pico de potência concêntrica
do levantamento terra e também
excêntrica potência média trabalho total
e percepção de esforço dos
participantes o estudo contou com a
participação de 20 homens taiwaneses ou
taiwaneses média de 22 anos índice de
massa corporal de 26 todos eram
praticantes regulares de exercício de
força e não apresentavam condições de
saúde aparentes então eram
saudáveis os participantes realiz a
mesma sessão de exercício de resistência
em duas ocasiões diferentes após o
aquecimento eles enxaguar a boca com 25
ml de solução de maltodextrina que é
muito utilizado né muita gente compra
isso em lo suplemento esportivo para dar
uma energia rápida durante atividade
para quem não tem resistência insulínica
não tem problema mas realmente é um
carboidrato que pode dar pico de
glicemia em pessoas pré-diabéticas então
era uma solução de Maltodextrina
a 6%
ou usou também Placebo teve um grupo
Placebo que usou água pura então eles
usavam esse enxague por 20 segundos e em
seguida cpir a
solução imediatamente após usaram um
treinador de fly whel para realizar
cinco séries de seis repetições
levantamento ter meno três minutos de
descanso entre cada série então as
sessões foram separadas por um período
de ch ou seja de sem fazer nada de uma
semana Então os resultados mostraram que
comparado ao Placebo o enxague bucal com
maltodestrina Aumentou a potência
concêntrica e excêntrica de pico a
potência média e o trabalho Total
realizado de forma interessante mesmo
realizando mais trabalho a percepção de
esforço dos participantes não mudou
entre as
condições Então já sabemos que a
ingestão de carboidratos é muito
conhecida por melhorar o desempenho
exercícios curtos no entanto a pesquisa
indica que os carboidratos podem agir
como um sinal pro sistema nervoso
central alterando o recrutamento de
unidades motoras e aumentando a produção
de força enche agora a boca com a
solução de carboidrato
ativa regiões do cérebro relacionadas à
atividade motora motivação e
recompensa contribuindo para uma maior
produção de força voluntária então quer
dizer não é simplesmente a energia do
carboidrato ou a capacidade que tem de
estimular insulina parece que tem na
própria boca receptores que levam
mensagem pro cérebro que fazem o cérebro
aumentar a atividade motora motivação e
recompensa vejam como é interessante
isso né bem semelhante com o conceito do
adoante que não tem caloria mas quando
você coloca o adoçante na boca o cérebro
entende que aquilo lá é carboidrato
apesar de não ter caloria e manda o
pâncreas produzir mais insulina veja
como o corpo já é adaptado para
determinadas situações de estímulo mesmo
que você não receba
caloria um detalhe interessante é que o
enxague bucal com carboidrato melhorou o
desempenho mesmo os participantes
estando bem alimentados Olha só
evidência sugere que o o efeito pode ser
mais benéfico após o jejum prolongado ou
em estado de depressão de glicogênio Ou
seja pessoas estão fazendo uma dieta aí
baixa quantidade de carboidrato ou ão em
jejum prolongado estudos anteriores
também mostraram que o
cmr que é o enxague bucal né pode
beneficiar mais o exercício de
resistência de corpo inteiro realizados
em jejum ou estado de depressão de
glicogênio então isso aqui poderia ser
uma estratégia para quem está em jejum
ou quem tá fazendo dieta quieto ou dieta
baixa carboidrato eh a pessoa pode estar
fazendo enxague de
maltodextrina e não necessariamente
cortar o jejum bem interessante isso
aqui para quem gosta de fazer atividade
física obrigado eu tô tentando convencer
Dr an Paula participar da Live
aí Boa noite Eliane nild ão concluindo
sobre esse estudo encha agora a boca com
uma solução de carboidrato
tá travado Não não é porque tá tendo
oscilação de energia aí apago toda hora
os monitores
aqui então voltando a assunto ench agora
a bocco com uma solução de carboidrato
antes de exercício de existência pode
aumentar o número total de repetições
realizadas aumentar então o desempenho
na
musculação especialmente exercício de
corpo inferior e feitos em jejum então é
interessante esse estudo eu vou até
experimentar isso aí tô achando
bem interessante no entanto mais
pesquisas são necessárias para entender
completamente os benefícios então se
você está buscando maneira de melhorar o
desempenho nos treinos um enxague bucal
com carboidrato no caso maltodestrina
pode ser uma estratégia simples e
eficaz beleza
pessoal estão ouvindo bem
né ela tá falando aqui Estela Mares ela
participa com frequência das lives e ela
tá dizendo aqui participa dout Aninha tá
Estela um super beijo a nossa super
atleta do consultório ano que vem vamos
fazer patrocínios
hein me digam se vocês estão ouvindo bem
a voz da Ana Paula tá e a minha voz
também então o próximo
artigo é um estudo fascinante que
investigou como é que é a combinação de
uma diet baixa em fmap ou seja uma dieta
baixa em alimentos que fermentam né
basicamente isso e suplementação de
triptofano que vai virar 5
htp triptofano é muito usado para
aumentar tanto serotonina quanto
melatonina Então como é que se poderia
aliviar a dor abdominal causada por
constipação né interessante Então a
dieta fodmap mais el triptofano para
melhorar a constipação
a Estela tá dizendo que tá ouvindo bem
enilde também que
bom então se você conhece alguém que
sofre de constipação ou você mesmo sofre
disso é bom você prestar atenção nessa
parte aqui o objetivo do estudo então
foi avaliar o efeito de uma dieta baixa
em fmap com ou sem suplementação com
triptofano na constipação
especificamente medindo a dor abdominal
os fodmaps S um grupo de carboidratos
que podem ser difíceis de digerir para
algumas pessoas e causam muitos gases e
sintomas desconfortáveis
gastrintestinais A pesquisa foi
conduzida com 100 adultos na Polônia
idade média de 72 anos então eram idosos
né A maioria deles destes 60 foram
diagnosticados com constipação usando os
critérios de Roma 4 esse critério de
Roma são os critérios que se usa para
diagnosticar síndrome intestino irritado
a maioria dos participantes eram homens
mas também havia um grupo significativo
de mulheres os participantes foram
divididos em dois grupos e seguiram uma
dieta baixa em fmap durante 12 semanas a
dieta era constituída de 1200 MG de
triptofano proviniente de alimentos além
de uma ingestão equilibrada de proteínas
carboidratos gorduras fibras e calorias
diárias um dos grupos também tomou 500
mg de elet triptofan duas vezes ao a dia
na fma de suplemento então após 12
semanas o grupo que seguiu a dieta baixa
em fodmap com suplementação de elit
triptofano relatou uma melhora
significativa nas classificações de dor
abdominal em comparação com o grupo que
seguiu apenas a dieta baixa em fodmap
isso sugere que a suplementação de l
triptofano pode oferecer benefícios
adicionais no alívio da dor associado a
constipação vamos mencionar alguns
pontos aqui algumas limitações do estudo
ausência de um grupo Placebo né que é
importante né no estudo anterior que eu
falei para vocês ali do enxague bucal né
com carboidrato tinha Placebo Então esse
estudo aqui com triptofano não teve
grupo
Placebo e o tamanho pequeno da amra
semem pessoas são fatores que têm que
ser levado em consideração e afetam a
confiança então lógico como é todo o
estudo acaba concluindo mais pesquisa
necessárias para confirmar esses achados
e compreender melhor os mecanismos
desenvolvidos concluindo o estudo então
sugere que a suação ou até o uso de
alimentos ricos em
triptofano junto a umaa baixa em F map
pode ser uma estratégia eficaz para
reduzir a dor abdominal causado pela
constipação né No entanto devido à
limitações que já mencionamos é
essencial que novos estudos sejam
realizados com mais gente e com grupo
placebo
Mas você pode tentar em casa se você tem
constipação experimentar fazer a diet
fmap e supar triptofano junto acho que é
bem seguro vale a pena você testar isso
daí terceiro artigo do dia é um estudo
inovador envolvendo hidrogênio né por
isso que eu achei interessante de est
falando com
vocês Esse estudo investiga como é que
inalação de mais rico em hidrogênio
antes de um teste de ciclismo poderia
afetar a fadiga pós exercício Será que
essa técnica poderia realmente ajudar a
reduzir a fadiga e melhorar o desempenho
vamos juntos descobrir isso daí esse
estudo investigou os efeitos da inalação
de gás rico em hidrogênio antes do
exercício sobre a fadiga e a fadiga foi
avaliada utilizando uma escala visual
analógica e monitorando o desempenho dos
participantes durante o ciclismo outros
desfechos avaliados foram a percepção de
esforço e os níveis sanguíneos de
lactato que é um marcador assim de que o
músculo Fez bastante esforço né porque o
lactato é um subproduto da glicólise
aeróbica e também marcadores de estress
oxidativo com atividade da glutationa
peroxidase e radicais doxil então o
estudo contou com a participação de 24
homens idade de média 21 anos eram
ativos e não não apresentavam condições
de saúde ou seja
doenças Então os
participantes realizaram teste de
ciclismo inicial para determinar quanto
tempo conseguiam pedalar 80% de potência
máxima durante a intervenção eles
realizaram dois testes de ciclismos
separados pedalando 80% da potência
máxima pelo mesmo tempo registrado no
teste Inicial aproximadamente 60 minutos
antes desses testes eles inalaram o gás
Rico gênio ou gás Placebo aqui ele não
especifica o que que foi o Placebo
imediatamente após o teste de ciclismo
os participantes relataram fadiga
percebida realizaram teste de salto com
contramovimento e tiveram amostras de
sangue coletadas então a fadiga
percebida também foi avaliada 30 e 60
minutos após os testes e amostras de
sangue adicionais foram coletadas nesses
intervalos a fadiga foi ainda medida
pela frequência de pedaladas dos
participantes em 10 segmentos de 30
segundos durante os testes de
ciclismo Então os testes foram separados
por um período de washout de 7 dias e os
participantes foram instruídos a evitar
exercícios vigorosos 48 horas antes dos
Testes e consumiram uma refeição
padronizada antes de cada teste
abstendo-se de consumir qualquer
alimento ou bebida adicional então eles
fizeram asso bem eh formulada aí com
design bom os resultados mostraram que a
fadiga subjetiva foi melhor ou menor com
gás de hidrogênio em comparação com
Placebo imediatamente após o teste
ciclismo mas não 30 ou 60 minutos depois
além disso a
rpe foi menor com gás de hidrogênio
imediatamente após o teste de ciclismo e
a frequência de pedaladas durante o
último segmento de 30 segundos foi maior
com gás de hidrogênio mas não houve
diferença entre a as condições nos
outros nove segmentos o desempenho no
teste de salto não diferiu entre as
condições então para os biomarcadores
sanguíneos os níveis de lactato foram
mais altos com gás Placebo do que com
gás hidrogênio 30 e 60 minutos após os
testes de ciclismo e a capacidade de
inibir radicais livres de hidroxila foi
maior Ou seja melhor com o gás de
hidrogênio do que com Placebo
imediatamente após mas não houve
diferença entre as condições 30 ou 60
minutos após os testes não houve
diferença entre as condições para
atividade da glutationa peroxidase que é
um enzima muito importante antioxidante
de
detox então é importante notar que os
pesquisadores não conseguiram medir
diretamente as concentração de
hidrogênio entrando no corpo a partir do
gás rico em hidrogênio devido a
limitações técnicas Então essa é uma
limitação importante desse estudo que
deve ser considerada ao interpretar
resultados então concluindo a inalação
de gás rico em hidrogênio antes de um
teste de ciclismo Parece sim reduzir a
fadiga subjetiva e melhora alguns
marcadores de desempenho e estess
oxidativo imediatamente após exercício
no entanto esses efeitos não se
mantiveram 30 ou 60 minutos após o
exercício Ou seja é um efeito frusto é
um efeito
temporário embora os resultados sejam
promissores mais pesquisas são
necessárias para entender completamente
os benefícios e limitações dessa
intervenção né então é uma forma de você
melhorar desempenho apesar de não ser
muito prático né você inalar hidrogênio
e ter que sair correndo fazer exercício
logo em seguida porque se você fizer
segundo Esse estudo 60 minutos
depois já vai
ter passado o efeito do hidrogênio
né Bem pessoal então vamos para as
perguntas
Boa noite
blandon que entrou agora a
pouco eu vou dividir com vocês aqui a
tela das
perguntas tá aqui do meu lado
hein ver se
ela nos ajuda aqui na live deixa eu
aumentar aqui o tamanho da figura aliás
da da letra Liane pergunta quais seriam
os
[Música]
benefícios do niagen no caso niagen uma
forma de vitamina B3 tá que é a
nicotinamida ribosídeo em relação ao
hexanicotinato de inositol boa pergunta
primeiro é o preço é o preço do linhagem
é puxado
viu na verdade quanto mais perto do nadh
é mais caro tá porque a vitamina B3 é o
precursor
nadh e hoje já existe nadh para uso
injetável injetável que nós utilizamos
nos pacientes com questões demenciais já
tem algum tempo né não é novidade Já tem
alguns anos já que que tem isso daí
implantes subcutâneos existe implante
subcutâneo de
nadh tá geralmente a gente usa o
hexanicotinato inositol para
redução de lipídios séricos
triglicérides aumento do HDL
colesterol não é o principal para
questão de energia tá porque o niagen
que nicotinamida ribosídeo ele tem maior
absorção maior
biodisponibilidade ele é uma de
liberação rápida enquanto exan conato de
liberação
lenta ele é muito mais eficaz na
elevação nos níveis de nadh ou NAD de
mais do que o exel
nicotinato Então quando você tá pensando
em melhorar energia mitocondrial é
melhor você usar o niagen se você tiver
condições se você não tiver condições
você pode usar até a própria niacina só
que a niacina que não é o exen
nicotinato de inositol vai te dar o
flush né que é bem desagradável na
maioria das
pessoas mas o ex incal também não é a
forma mais barata de
B3 então o ex nicotinato não foi tão
estudado para verificar esse efeito de
aumento de energia já o unag Sim ele foi
melhor estudado para isso E também o
niagen vai proteger contra o
envelhecimento celular e danos ao DNA e
quanto que o ex continuado você vai usar
mais para questão do colesterol como eu
já falei
Quando você pensa na saúde
cardiovascular de modo geral você vai
tentar usar mais unag porque ele vai
ajudar na saúde do coração da
mitocôndria do mioso do
coração e quando você tá pensando mais
em colesterol você vai usar o ex anicat
inositol e tem também alguns estudos
falando que o niag tem propriedades anti
envelhecimento além de melhorar a função
cognitiva
tá então resumindo o niag é mais
facilmente absorvido e também processado
ele aumenta mais o nível de energia do
que o exan conato vai contribuir pra
produção de NAD mais ou NAD h
mais então isso vai proporcionar aumento
de energia mitocondrial e efeitos
antienvelhecimento
e quando usar então exato quando você
tem menos condição financeira e quando
você quer utilizar mais no sentido de
reduzir o colesterol ou metal HDL
colesterol no modo
geral e pode ajudar também a diminuir
ansiedade e estress
beleza próxima
[Música]
pergunta do Carlos Caro Dr Alan Dutra
uso de fogão de indução é uma maravilha
mas aliás pois permite
temperatura desejada evitando a
desnaturação de proteínas Há alguma
contraindicação no uso dessa tecnologia
que eu saiba só micro-ondas e raios
ultravioletas são prejudiciais
a questão sabe Carlos é que esse tipo de
fogão de indução ele usa um campo
magnético se você já tá num ambiente com
muita energia eletromagnética perto de
torre de transmissão de energia perto de
torre de transmissão de celular perto de
vários aparelhos já que produzem
eletromagnética é mais uma coisa para
gerar um campo eletromagnético agora eu
não conheço um estudo dizendo que esses
fogões fazem mal mas você tem que intuir
que se você já vive num ambiente com
muita radiação eletromagnética pode não
ser uma
boa vamos falar um pouquinho das
vantagens do fogão de indução ele
permite um controle preciso de
temperatura ele é diferente do
micro-ondas no sentido que ele evita a
desnaturação de
proteínas ele tem uma eficiência
energética alta ele aquece rapidamente e
reduz o consumo de energia ele tem uma
questão de segurança porque a superfície
Fica fria então Eh reduz muito o risco
de
queimadura só porém tem um problema aqui
eh ele interfere com dispositivos
médicos então seu
a pessoa que tá utilizando tem
marca-passo ou outro aparelho que tenha
magnetismo ele vai ter problema devido
aos Campos
magnéticos quer falar aluma coisa não é
sobre Marc Passos sim eu tô falando
[Música]
agora então também tem uma vantagem
nesse de indução que é fácil de
limpar mas tem um detalhezinho aí você
tem que ter uma panela e frigideira
compatível com indução Então tem que ter
metais ferro magnéticos nas
panelas Então pode ter um custo grande
adicional aí trocar todas as panelas da
sua
casa Outra vantagem seria a ausência de
emissões de gases como monóxido de
carbono que acontece em fogões a gás mas
o campo eletromagnético Além das pessoas
que TM macapa e outros aparelhos
eletrônicos corpo pode ser um problema
para pessoas que T sensibilidade à
radiação eletromagnética que antes Se
achava que isso daí era maluí mas hoje
tem realmente comprovação que existe
pessoas que são muito sensíveis a isso
podem ter destruidos de humor tontura
zumbido fogue mental fadiga essas coisas
a ch doença do wi-fi né Não só do wi-fi
né de qualquer radiação eletromagnética
tá Então na verdade eu diria o seguinte
tente evitar essa
tecnologia se você tem sensibilidade a
radiação eletromagnética ou se você já
tá exposto a muitos Campos que hoje é
cada vez mais comum até também que tá
aumentando muito com a questão do 5g
ok e vamos esperar estudos né mais
específicos falando dessa tecnologia e
paraa saúde aqui eu não conheço pelo
menos
menos Tiago a chagando rodiola para
suporte ao tratamento das adrenais é
melhor fazer uso combinado ou uso
alternado algum problema em fazer uso
contínuo de algumas delas a gente eu
nunca recomendo que você use fitoterapia
contínuo sem acompanhamento médico Ok
mas de qualquer maneira você pode usar
sim os dois juntos eles são
adaptógenos que são muito utilizados na
Medicina integrativa na medicina
funcional eles ajudam a regular o
cortisol e também ajuda a calmar o
cérebro Na verdade o efeito deles é mais
cerebral do que adrenal e realmente a
maioria dos adaptógenos reduz cortisol
Então se seu cortisol já tá muito baixo
Talvez seja uma contraindicação para
utilizar mas a chaga que o nome
científico é itania sonífera ela tem um
efeito maior de reduzir o cortisol do
que a rodiola
a rodiola tem uma propriedade de
aumentar a produção de ATP melhora a
resposta ao stresse oxidativo ela vem da
medicina tradicional chinesa e russa e a
Chanda vem da Índia né da Medicina
elveda pode ser utilizar tranquilamente
os dois
[Música]
juntos já já fiz muitas vezes
isso agora se você for usar sem
acompanhamento médico eu sugiro que faça
uso por 90 dias
somente algumas pessoas têm intolerância
gastri intestinal a chaga e a rodiola
pode causar insone irritabilidade de
algumas
pessoas pode ser uma boa opção para
desmame de
antidepressivo depende né para desmamar
antidepressivo Geralmente eu uso mais
coisa não uso só adaptógeno não eu
costumo usar alguns fitoterápicos que
tem efeito antidepressivo como a
cava-cava e a erva de São João perum mas
dá para associar adaptógeno
sim próxima pergunta do Thiago Existe
alguma erva suplemento para suporte
renal assim como tem para fígado Boa
pergunta tem tem algumas plantas que se
utiliza para rim e no sentido de serem
diuréticas tá então entre elas tem a uva
urce que tem efeito também
antiinfeccioso além de efeito
antiinflamatório pode ser utilizado em
pacientes que TM intestino irritável que
tem cibo né proliferação de bactérias no
intestino delgado ouv ú é muito usada
para
isso e ela pode ajudar também a tratar
infecções urinárias pelo efeito
antiinfeccioso a cavalinha ter efeito
diurético ajuda a eliminar toxinas então
é interessante porém tomar cuidado que a
cavalinha pode causar deficiência de
tiamina se usado em excesso aliás eu
esqueci de falar uma coisa da panela de
indução né a Dra Ana Paula encontrou um
texto que fala que a indução a panela de
indução desculpa o forno de indução pode
dar deficiência de vitamina B1 né
tiamina no cozimento da Carne ela
diminuiu em até 25% a quantidade de
tiamina e nas verduras e frutas também
que serem forem cozidas diminui bastante
o as vitaminas do complexo B então Fique
atento também então cumprimentando a
pergunta anterior do Forno de indução
vai dar uma reduzida em vitaminas do
complexo
b e a cavalinha que nós estamos
discutindo aqui agora na outra pergunta
também pode diminuir a B1 se você
consumir a cavalinha em excesso o dente
de leão é ótimo para detox é um
diurético natural
também também ajuda na questão renal por
ser um diurético o Cranberry né como
vocês sabem evita infecções urinárias
então pode ser utilizado para ajudar na
saúde
renal porém o cranell ele pode ter agir
com anticoagulantes Então tem que ficar
atento quanto a isso a salsinha é
diurética também ajuda na eliminação de
toxinas a raiz de alcaçus né o licorice
também pode proteger os rins porém como
o licorice tem glicerina ele pode
aumentar a pressão arterial e causar
hipertensão retenção de líquidos tomar
muito cuidado então não use licorice al
Caçu se você for hipertenso O astragalus
que é um adaptó muito interessante tem
ação positiva cerebral também tem função
renal tem propriedades antiinflamatórias
pro rim
certo então esses são os alguns
suplementos você pode utilizar paraa
função renal não tem um Fit terápico
né Maria Helena é possível melhorar o
intestino e ter menos problemas com
estamina ou não tem nada a ver tem a ver
sim né a saúde testinal ela tá
intimamente ligada à capacidade do corpo
de processar e regular estamina
pois o intestino saudável pode melhorar
a função das enzimas que degradam a
estamina como é o caso da diamina oxidas
Dal então
estamina ela é uma mina biogênica ela
tem vários papéis no corpo ela é uma das
principais substâncias que os mastócitos
liberam quando são
ativados então a estamina ajuda na
regulação da resposta imunológica na
secreção gástrica também e na função
neurológica então ele atua também como
neurotransmissor porém excesso de
histamina pode causar sintomas muito
desconfortáveis como coceira no corpo
dor de cabeça enxaqueca problemas
digestivos e
rinite as principais enzimas que lidam
com a estamina são a diamina oxidase que
eu já comentei que degrada ela na parte
intestinal ajuda a diminuir a estamina
no intestino e outra enzima do sangue
que é a estamina n metiltransferase
hnmt e ela degrada a estamina de maneira
intracelular e também no sangue
principalmente no fígado e nos
rins quando a pessoa tem uma saúde
intestinal
comprometida ela vai ter inflamação
aumento da permeabilidade intestinal que
é o intestino hiper permeável liqu Gut e
geralmente disbiose que o desequilíbrio
da microbiota quando acontece isso reduz
a eficácia da dalda de aminox isso leva
uma acumulação de estamina então é
importante pessoas que TM esses sintomas
tem uma dieta baixa estamina a própria
dieta F map tem essa questão de baixa
mas tem algumas dietas específicas para
baixar a estamina os principais
alimentos que seriam ricos nesse
elemento são Queijos envelhecidos
alimentos fermentados carne processada
álcool certos vegetais como beringela
espinafre né evitar alimentos guardados
na geladeira H muito tempo também
acumulam estamina evitar alimentos
processados e pessoas que têm muito
problema lá com reações histamínicas né
intolerância histamina pode pode estar
utilizando o da né como suplemento a
diaminoxidase que na manipulação chama
adid o uso de probióticos podem ajudar
também melhorando a flora intestinal e
melhorando a degradação da estamina uso
de fibras solúveis como é o caso de
inulina ou
frutooligossacarídeos também pode ajudar
usar antiinflamatórias intestinais como
é o caso de cúrcuma e ômega-3 pode
ajudar alimentos antioxidantes como
frutas vermelhas uso da glutamina também
bem interessante do zinco da Aloe Vera
que ajudam a diminuir o intestino hiper
permeável
especialmente o zinco
carnosina meditação
mindfulness yoga AJ no sono
[Música]
adequado vamos paraa próxima
pergunta Maria Helena beber café no
dejejum pela manhã prejudica a absorção
de vitaminas sim existe
interações pode influenciar a absorção
de algumas vitaminas e minerais sabemos
que Café tem vários benefícios paraa
saúde melhora a concentração melhora a
cognição
mas sim pode impactar por exemplo na
absorção de Ferro o café pode reduzir de
forma significativa a absorção do ferro
vegetal ou seja o ferro não M isso não
acontece com o ferro que tem na carne
por exemplo ou no
fígado isso acontece os porque os
polifenóis do café se ligam ao ferro e
formam complexos impedindo absorção
desse
mineral então é interessante você usar o
ferro pelo menos 2 horas depois do café
o consumo excessivo nesse caso de café
pode também aumentar a excreção urinária
de Cácio então você pode eliminar mais
Calcio pela urina se você tomar muito
café
e o café pode aumentar a produção de
ácido gástrico que pode influenciar a
absorção de vitamina B12 em pessoas com
hipocloridria Então pode até ajudar a
absorção de B12 o café em pessoas que
têm esse problema aí da hipocloridria
já o magnésio o impacto do uso do café é
bem menor e Geralmente os efeitos são
mínimos e não
significativos Maria Helena por ter
problemas em ingerir vitamina D3 todos
os dias problema com K2 posso tomar
injeção de 600.000 quantas vezes no ano
vou ter algum efeito colateral eu já
estou sabendo que preciso de receita tem
alguma dosagem injetável que não precise
não todos os medicamentos injetáveis não
tem como você comprar sem receita pelas
vias normais tá a não ser que a empresa
tá te vendendo tá sendo
antiética a questão da dosagem da
frequência Varia muito pessoa para
pessoa então você tem que monitorar os
níveis no sangue porque as pessoas
pensam que tom quando uma injeção de
600.000 vai subir muito rápido a
vitamina D isso não acontece geralmente
porque ela fica armazenada no tecido
gorduroso e vai sendo liberado aos
poucos uma vez Tomei duas doses né de
600000 de uma vez não foi no começo da
pandemia depois tamb mais uns do meses
depois né E a minha vitamina D não
estourou mesmo
assim de maneira grosseira seria a cada
se meses tá mas é muito
pessoa para
pessoa tem pacientes que tem alterações
nos receptores da vitamina D e mesmo com
dose alta ele não consegue sustentar por
muito temp é mas ção né São pessoas que
tem mutação no vdr né que no vitam D
receptor você tem essa mutação não você
não
investigou só acha que tem você não ten
certeza vai se eu F né dois meses sem
tomar vitamina del ela cai para baixo de
15 não toma sol também né
Boa noite Eloí Boa noite
Cristina já te respondo aí a dúvida nild
tá que eu vou responder Primeiro as
perguntas do documento Fátima Oliveira
Qual a proporção de Celene zinco para
tratamento de no de tireoide isso varia
de pessoa para pessoa tá mas maneira
grosseira o serene você vai usar entre
100 a 200 microg por dia e o zinco por
volta de 15 30 mg por dia mas isso
variar de pessoa para pessoa
tá tem que medir no sangue e se se
possível até dentro da hemácia né fazer
a dosagem intra eritrocitária se for
algo acessível pro
paciente interessante além de
suplementar comer alimentos ricos em
selênio como é o caso do castanha do
Pará né ou do Brasil e também o zinco
que é a fonte
mais fácil assim é carne vermelha frutos
do mar e sementes né no caso noses e
castanhas também vão ser fontes de
zinco Fátima quais os minerais vitaminas
para nódulos na tiri tem vários tá
selênico já foi comentado zinco já foi
comentado O iodo né importante eu
recomendo
e para vocês sem acompanhamento médico
especialmente vocês utiliz á de 150 200
microg de iodo kelp evitem o lugol sem
acompanhamento médico o magnésio também
vai ajudar bastante o ferro também vai
ajudar bastante B12 as vitaminas
Complexo B especialmente a B12 a
vitamina D ajuda a vitamina A ajuda a
vitamina E
Ajuda também o metilfolato vai ajudar
também tem um vídeo da semana passada em
que fala sobre os oito alimentos
importantes para tiró no canal do
YouTube só dar uma olhada lá também ISO
isso tá então resumindo selenio zinco
iodo ferro magnésio vitaminas d a e e as
do Complexo B de modo geral vão ajudar
no nóos de
tireoide Estela tô vendo que você tá
falando aí sobre a garrafa de hidrogênio
Depois você conta pra gente se você faz
mas ela falou garrafa de hidrogênio com
inalador fazer uma
fazer antes a inalação com hidrogênio se
você achou que a sua performance foi
melhor tá passa sua experiência por
favor Que ótimo mas você comprou uma
garrafa e o inalador é isso Eu não
entendi quando você colocou garrafa de
hidrogênio com inalador deve ser osos
dois
né imagino eu perguntas do
Eliseu a pergunta vai ser maior que a
resposta pelo
jeito para melhorar a duração do Son de
qualquer pessoa que tá praticando uma
excelente higiene do
sono mas ainda só consegue dormir 5
horas por dia você tem que considerar
várias abordagens
aí então vamos lá uma coisa importante
elizu tem tem pessoas que são pequenos
dormidor que com 5 horas de sono
conseguem completar todas as fases não
alteram cortisol não não se não acordam
fadigados e são os pequen nos dormidor
então existem questões individuais nem
sempre dormir só 5 horas é patológico é
mas a maioria das pessoas vai ter
deficiência de sono com esse com esse
regime sim bem essa história que você tá
falando aqui repetir uma afirmação como
amanhã quero acordar 6 horas da manhã
Poderia ajudar programar a mente
subconsciente sim mas não é garantido
que vai aumentar a qualidade do sono tá
Pelo menos eu não conheço nenhum texto
falou
disso bem vamos falar de alguns métodos
para aumentar a duração do
[Música]
Sono procure ajustar gradualmente o
horário de dormir e acordar incrementos
de 15 a 30 minutos por exemplo ir pra
cama 15 minutos mais cedo Cada noite até
atingir o objetivo de 7 horas ou 8 horas
de sono tenta fazer meditação
mindfulness respiração profunda yoga
antes do dormir para aumentar o
relaxamento e a qualidade do sono você
pode também utilizar os suplementos que
você comentou aqui
melatonina glicina magnésio camomila
Valeriana também a eu acresentar essa
lista Aí
Mulungu 5 htp l lisina o próprio gaba
Tem várias coisas que pode ajudar no
sono Melissa você é Melissa também óleo
essencial de lavanda laranja doce
isso existe também uma terapia cognitiva
comportamental que você pode considerar
eh conversar com o terapeuta para
identificar e alterar padrões de
pensamento e comportamento que afetam o
sono procurar evitar a exposição à luz à
noite reduzir o máximo a exposição à luz
artificial nesse horário e aumentar a
exposição a luz natural pela manhã além
de fazer exercício regular que também
ajuda a melhorar a qualidade do som
ok mas tá perguntando de marca de pro
tem que não tem todos esses agentes aqui
que vocês estão lendo na tela
aqui geralmente Eliseu eu não peço para
as pessoas comprarem o em manipulação
com exceção da ente tá que gente eu tem
vários u pro interessantes Mas
geralmente eles não
manipulam individualmente eles vendem na
loja da essentia
É verdade que o nosso organismo não
consegue absorver mais do que 24 g de
whei proteí de uma só vez não isso já
caiu por terra tá esse limite não existe
mais as Depende de pessoa para pessoa
mas dá para absorver mais do que
isso não existe intervalo mínimo para
poder absorver o eprin também
[Música]
não bem marcas tá que eu encontrei
que vai
corresponder essas características aqui
que você pediu
fomas esse daqui trabalha com e
manipulado fam eficácia e f
Nostra e os que não são manipulados Now
Sports Way Protein Isolado book Powers
por Way Isolate 90 e naked Way tá então
Max que eu encontrei com essas
características Mas você pode também
fazer pesquisas na
internet bem o intervalo que eu sugiro
para você ingerir proteínas entre TRS a
4 horas tá mas não quer dizer que você
não vai conseguir absorver se você
diminuir esse
intervalo pergunta Maria Helena Notre
exona tem contraindicação você deve tá
falando da Notre exon de baixa dosagem
né o
ldn bem a
contraindicação principal é pessoas que
usam opiáceo Mas se a pessoa tiver
tomando opiáceo digamos de manhã você
pode usar ldn à noite mas se a pessoa
tiver tomando opi ácio várias vezes ao
longo do dia vai ser complicado usar o
ldn isso porque eles têm efeito
completamente divergentes né o opiode
vai estimular o receptor e o ldn vai
bloquear o receptor Então não vai
funcionar se você utilizar os dois
próximos de
horário pessoas que TM doença hepática
muito grave também não devem usar
ldn mulheres que estão amamentando ou
grávidas também você vê que na verdade
tem estudos mostrando que aid na
gravidez até ajuda o feto ajuda o bebê
Mas dependendo da fonte que você
consultar vai dizer que é contraindicado
na gravidez e alergia né também de modo
geral Ela é bem tolerada mas tem pessoas
que sentem muito efeito colateral
especialmente sono
conturbado sono muito vívido ou insônia
que são os principais efeitos colaterais
aí do ldn algumas pessoas também T dor
de cabeça fadiga e letargia mas são
efeitos menos comuns
aí tem uma pergunta que fizeram aqui no
WhatsApp foi Cristiane Ulisses que fez
se que ela pagou mas eu tinha tinha
copiado aqui protocolo Coimbra tem
contraindicação tem pessoas por exemplo
não conseguem fazer
a dieta com restrição de cálcio é uma
contraindicação pessoas tem suficiência
renal grave também é uma contraindicação
pessoas que já TM hipercalcemia por
algum motivo como hiperparatiroidismo é
contraindicação pessoas que usam
diuréticos tiazídicos né que são aqueles
diuréticos que fazem perder potássio
eles podem aumentar os livos de cálcio
no sangue então tem que tomar cuidado
com esse grupo que usa diurético
tiazídico tá são essas são as
contraindicações que eu me lembro aqui
Vamos as perguntas
aqui ao
[Música]
vivo se eu tenho experiência com
ostarine 20 MG por ml para Grande massa
eu usei algumas vezes mas hoje em dia já
tem mais uns dois ou três anos que o
ostarine e os outros sarms foram
proibidos na manipulação então tem
bastante tempo que eu não uso mas eu
tive alguns bons resultados ostarine sim
mas tá perguntando por qu nild você
achou algum lugar que vende ostarine
porque no Brasil tá
proibido eu estou usando o lugol sem
acompanhamento por favor me explica
porque que não pode não pode porque 1/3
das pessoas que tomam o lugol mesmo
tomando cenho junto podem ter inflamação
na tireóide por isso que eu não
recomendo utilizar o lugol sem
acompanhamento
Ah sim você comprou uma garrafa com tem
que tem inalador não conheci Estela
depois você mostra pra gente a garrafa
tem inalador junto na mes no mesmo equo
legal hein
[Música]
é bem Já respondi isso aqui né Você
entendeu a explicação tam
miquinha vou esperar você responder aí
Ah entendeu a explicação tá miquinha
temos mais dúvidas ao vivo pessoal acho
que eu vou encerrar com 50 minutos
estamos quase com 50 minutos de Live
aqui que que foi você tá
ver
Não você falou pouco tem que falar mais
vé pergunta quantos viram vídeo se tem
dúvida sobre vídeo ah sim quantos de
vocês viram o vídeo do canal alternativo
do vlog sobre a doença autoimune
cerebral de
B12 Enio tá dizendo aqui tem gente que
está vendendo ostarine É mas tá trazendo
de Fora contrabando
né e o risco de ser falsificado também é
é mesmo mesmo problema de você comprar
anabolizante né S nunca tenho certeza se
o negócio que tá vindo aí pelo
contrabando é real ou não né depis dá
uma hepatite medicamentosa uma
pancreatite medicamentosa
e acaba espirrando para tudo que é lado
né então
é
verdade Quais são as possíveis causas de
síncope síncope n é um tipo de desmaio
tá que geralmente acontece com redução
da circulação cerebral tá então é
síncope é diferente por exemplo De
vertigem que é uma outra tontura mas que
envolve problema de labirinto de ouvido
interno que a pessoa fica com perda de
equilíbrio e sensação rotatória tá sí
geralmente acontece quando a pressão cai
bruscamente Mas tem várias causas pode
ser problema no coração pode ser
problema nas artérias do pescoço pode
ser problema numa artéria dentro do
cérebro que mais
né cusí arritmia cardíaca né porque aí a
pessoa por momento o coração não vai
bater de uma forma eficiente aí o sangue
não chega ao cérebro de uma maneira
adequada e pode causar síncope placa
suboclusiva de carot é mas aí já tá
dentro da alterações de circulação das
artérias do pescoço né que eu acabei de
comentar aqui tem algum motivo vilde
para você tá interessada nisso em
bem eu só vou esperar n responder e vou
est encerrando
tá o Eliseu não tá online hoje hein
exceção né quase sempre tá online Oi ele
tá curtindo o feriado em Campos de
Jordão no frio eu não sei eu nem lembro
que estado que ele mora ele mora em São
Paulo não
lembro
CTO entendeu direitinho
Paul tá fazendo propaganda minha nos nos
grupos que eu não tenho vergonha de
fazer autopromoção né
é que que isso para que eu não entendi
esse negócio que se as pessoas começarem
a querer informações por aí é complicado
então vou mandar um oi pro e-mail do
consultó pegar o link sobre o grupo de
apoiadores Ah tá
sal Doutor do pode ser de
160 salo diminuir noturno
emb
Ah por isso que está chovendo Elise
ausente É verdade viu
est você é ótimo quero ver seu filho
joga uma foto no grupo
hum o Artur hum a gente não compartilha
fotos Ana Paula não gosta viu ter que
respeitar ela viu não se el tem ela tem
um pouco de recei com essas coisas ei
caramba tá dando Ixe tá dando oscilação
de
energia aqui hoje o dia todo é por causa
da chuva bem pessoal vou encerrar tá por
causa que tá até caindo a energia aqui
um abraço para vocês um beijo no coração
tchau tchau tchau gente até próximo